>>Chade-Meng Tan: Good afternoon, everybody.
So have you ever had the experience of making
friends with somebody and then later discover
that he's a famous rock star? [laughs]
[laughter]
So I had that experience with our honored
guest today, Salman Ahmad.
I met him at a United Nations and I was impressed
with his talents, his personal kindness, and
his compassion. And so we sort of became like
instant friends.
And then I discovered that he's a famous rock
star. It's like a member of the biggest band
and long lasting rock back in South Asia called
Junoon and he's a national Pakistani icon.
And beyond being a rock star, Salman is also
an eminent humanitarian. He's a United Nations
Google ambassador. He played the first ever
rock concert in war torn Kashmir, and he's
the first Pakistani musician ever to perform
at a Nobel Peace Prize ceremony.
He is also helping to bring peace between
Pakistan and India and he's working to help
Pakistan's three million displaced people.
Such an amazing human being.
And my friends, please give a warm welcome
to my friend, Salman Ahmad.
[applause]
>>Salman Ahmad: Thank you.
>>Chade-Meng Tan: Thank you.
>>Salman Ahmad: Thanks for having me. Thank
you.
[sound of ticking]
Thank you and peace be upon you.
I've heard my friend Meng saying that the
culture here is of the "yes" culture, and
we don't ask for permission but we ask for
forgiveness. So I shall begin this talk with
asking your forgiveness as well.
[pause]
This is a time, 2011, the world is in flux;
cultures are in flux; there's a collision
of cultures happening and I find myself as
an artist born in Lahore Pakistan. Anybody
from Pakistan out there?
[pause]
So for anybody from India out there?
So as you know you guys are all at Google,
but most of the career choices you get growing
up in Pakistan or India, like the ones I got,
were two choices: doctor and doctor.
[laughter]
And that was drummed into me even before I
could learn how to say, "Mama" or "Papa."
Ami, Abba.
And so my life has been, growing in a culture
with certain do's and don'ts but thinking
completely out of the box.
My earliest memory, when I was growing up
we used to have family weddings in the backyard;
no five star hotels, no community centers,
backyards. And at our family weddings there
used to be Qawwali music. Anybody heard of
Qawwali music out there?
So my earliest memory was at a wedding where
I see two rows of musicians, a front row of
lead singers with harmoniums, and a back row
of Tabla players and hand clappers; strong
hand clappers.
And I was maybe six, seven years old but what
struck me was that the melody and the rhythm
it did something to my heart; went through
my ears and it connected with me, the vibrations
connected with me in such a way that it created
curiosity.
[pause]
What is that? What is that?
And one of the earliest melodies is of a poet
from South Asia, a renaissance man from the
12th century -- his name was Amir Khusro and
Hazat Amir Khusrau, created, was the father
of Qawwali music. And his sole reason for
listening to a lot of Bhajan music which was
around at that time, I mean that's what he
grew up with was listening to Hindu devotional
music, the Bhajan music. His mother was Indian,
his father was Persian, so he had a lot of
diverse cultural influences: Arabic folk poems,
Persian melodies and he fused Bhajan, Arabic
folk music, Persian poetry, and out of that
came Qawwali.
But although he was using existing building
blocks off elements that which were already
around, he came up with something completely
new and which took over the subcontinent.
As you know, the region which is now India,
Bangladesh, and Pakistan, Afghanistan very
diverse, so many different languages, so many
different faith traditions, ethnicities, yet
through music, the communication of music
he was able to bring Hindus and Muslims and
people from other,-- later on in the Sikh
tradition as well together in unity.
And the concept of unity was the reason. I
mean he didn't wanna be number one on MTV,
he didn't wanna be Facebooked or Twittered,
he was just making this music 'cause he felt
it in his soul.
And as a six year old, when I was listening
to this melody --
[plucks guitar string]
I have an electric acoustic which is not plugged
in so if you can't hear the chords --
[strums guitar]
forgive me.
[laughs]
[playing guitar and humming]
So Amir Khusro came up with this melody --
[playing guitar and singing in foreign language]
[playing guitar in background]
And as he played--
There was this pulse to it which goes like
this.
[playing guitar and counting]
One, two, three four. One, two, three, four.
So he asked people who ever were coming together
to just connect with the pulse. And I'll ask
you as well.
Two, three, four.
[playing guitar]
Put your hands together.
[sound of people clapping to music in background]
[playing guitar and singing in foreign language]
And as you just did, accelerated with the
beat as one.
[playing guitar and people clapping to music
in background]
[playing guitar and singing in foreign language;
tempo increasing]
Your turn.
[Salman Ahmad and audience singing in foreign
language]
Everyone.
[Salman Ahmad and audience singing in foreign
language]
[Salman Ahmad clapping; audience clapping
and singing in foreign language]
[Salman Ahmad singing in foreign language
and audience clapping]
Keep it going.
[Salman Ahmad singing and audience singing
and clapping]
[audience clapping and singing]
[Salman Ahmad singing with audience]
[Salman Ahmad playing guitar and singing with
audience who is clapping]
So that --
[applause]
Well, thank you for coming, coming along on
this experiment.
But what music does is that complete strangers
facing each other can attune, synergize, and
have empathy for each other.
And I've now been -- I graduated from medical
school and I told my parents, "Give me one
year to play music." But I didn't tell them
how many days in that one year. So they played
along and then they realized it's not gonna
happen to be a Sharif doctor.
[laughter]
And on this journey, as I've felt about the
Qawwali, when I was 11 years old my family
moved to the States, to New York. And for
the first two years I was there, I moved at
the age of 11, first two years I was there,
my two best friends were TV and radio.
And it seemed like, how do you make sense
of this culture which is so, so different
from where you grew up? Until one day a kid
in school by the name of Danny Spitz, who
went on to form the heavy metal band Anthrax,
he went to my high school. And he said, "Listen
Sal, you need to do something. You have to
get cool."
[laughter]
And cool? So he said, "I have this ticket
in my back pocket." Danny was always, he was
selling something, so he said, "I have this
ticket in my back pocket. You can have this
red ticket. And it's for Monday night at a
show at Madison Square Garden and if you come
to this show, you will become cool." It was
that simple.
And now I'm thinking in my head while he's
putting this ticket, there is my mother, conservative
Pakistani woman, sending me to a rock concert
in Madison Square Garden at the age of 13,
is not gonna happen.
But there was a whisper in my heart. Everybody
has a whisper in their heart, a passion, right?
My whisper said, "Get the ticket."
So I bought the ticket off of him and went
home and I told my mother that this rock concert
is happening and the entire school is going
to --
[laughter]
to see this rock concert and there's only
one ticket for a Monday night and I bought
this ticket.
So my mother Shaheen -- she looked into my
eyes and she said, "If you do drugs, I will
disown you."
[laughter]
[pause]
Then she drove me to Madison Square Garden.
And I tell this story in my book, "Rock & Roll
Jihad" as well. And as I got off three blocks
away from Madison Square Garden, I walk on
the pavement and I saw thousands and thousands
of kids long hair, torn jeans, peace signs,
and an expression which said, "dazed and confused."
And as I walked into the Garden it says, "Led
Zeppelin Live in Concert." And I didn't know
what Led Zeppelin was. It could have been
the Bay City Rollers for all I was concerned.
But what was interesting was this cultural,
this community because for the first hour
there was no band out there, there was just
like these layers of smoke everywhere --
[laughter]
which smelled kind of funny as well.
And so I was like this, almost like watching
it as a scientist of what happens [chuckles]
at a rock concert.
So after waiting for about an hour the lights
go down and these four guys come up on stage.
One of them has this two-headed guitar with
dragons painted on his pants and he starts
playing something like this.
[strumming guitar Led Zeppelin tune]
And as he plays in, the drums come in and
the keyboards come in. All of a sudden everybody
starts screaming, "Kashmir!"
[laughter]
[pause]
Now if you come from South Asia --
[laughter]
you know that that is nothing to cheer about.
[laughs]
[laughter]
Yet, but for those three hours that I stood
in the 63rd row watching Led Zeppelin perform,
it transformed me.
Here was something, I was a complete cultural
outsider, didn't know what the songs were
about, what the lyrics meant, but I just intuitively
understood; just the way I understood Qawwali
music. That this is something very, this is
familiar, this is powerful.
And so sound vibrations always stuck with
me as a teenager that sound vibrations are
not to be dismissed lightly, that this is
yet entertainment.
I've followed my path, the whisper I'm talking
to you about, there's a saying by the poet
Muhammad Iqbal he said and I'll translate
into English, he said, "That whisper in your
heart has strength. That whisper in your heart
has strength. It may not have wings but it
has the power to fly." [Speaks in Hindi].
That whisper in your heart.
And my whisper was saying that, "Yes, you're
stuck, you have all the reasons not to become
a musician. You have all the reasons not to
follow your heart, you have all the reasons
not to follow your passion, but this is who
you really are."
And I think once you start listening to the
whisper, it becomes louder and louder and
louder. And as I went through my career, and
my book is based on what I'm talking to you
about, I understood also that when you see
with the heart, all the masks fall down. Music
allows us to see with the heart.
And recently in the last, all my life, social
service because I went to med school, my wife
Samina who's here, is also a doctor. We understood
that social service, healing has to be part
of whatever we do in our lives.
So I've always tried to sort of balance arts
and culture and social service and our non-profit
organization SSGWI. There's a website for
it as well SSGWI dot org, uses arts and culture
to build dialog, to communicate and talk about
all kinds of things from India, Pakistan,
conflict resolution to HIV and AIDS and I
wanted to, I hope we're not running over time.
I just wanna show quickly two of the kind
of videos that using arts and culture we've
done.
The first is titled, Alvida. And it's about
a Pakistani woman who lives with HIV and AIDS,
lost her husband. This is a true story. Lost
her husband and then found herself ostracized
by a community in which there's great stigma,
there's great discrimination. And it was because
she stood up, she listened to the whisper
in her heart and she realized, "If I run away,
where can I run away?"
And her story was so empowering, so powerful
that I did a video for that.
This is titled Alvida.
[guitar music playing]
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
kaise kahu yeh raaz tujhe
mera dil de aawaz tujhe
yun hi rahe tu mere baad bhi
tujhe sukh de meri yaad bhi
alvida aa~
alvida alvida aa~
mera saath jo diya mere dost shukriya
alvida aa~
alvida
kaise kahu yeh raaz tujhe
mera dil de aawaz tujhe
yun hi rahe tu mere baad bhi
tujhe sukh de meri yaad bhi
[guitar playing]
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
meri zindagi mein na sakoon hai na karaar
hai
mere paas bas teri yaad hain
tera pyaar hain alvida aa~
alvida alvida aa~
mera saath jo diya mere dost shukriya
alvida aa~
alvida
[guitar playing]
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
teri chaahaton ke rahenge aaise silsilay
hain kathin magar koi mere jaisa tujhe mile
kaise kahu yeh raaz tujhe
mera dil de aawaz tujhe
yun hi rahe tu mere baad bhi
tujhe sukh de meri yaad bhi
alvida aa~
alvida alvida aa~
mera saath jo diya mere dost shukriya
[guitar music fades]
[applause]
>>Salman Ahmad: Thank you.
So this is an example of using arts and culture
to start a dialog, a difficult dialog. HIV
and AIDS is not only in Pakistan but India,
Afghanistan, Bangladesh, is a preventable
disease. But to communicate prevention is
the best cure, is very difficult. So we have
to think out of the box ideas. A lot of young
people in colleges saw the video and this
became number one on MTV they see.
And so it gets -- just like movies and books,
music and music video allows us this sort
of platform to start a dialog.
I want to give you another short example of
that. During the summer, the greatest single
natural disaster on the face of the planet
was the floods in Pakistan. And it was bigger
than Haiti, tsunami, and the Kashmir earthquake
put together, yet it got zero coverage, very
little coverage in the global media.
So I thought, "What can I do?" I mean, and
I looked at the tools that we have today,
Facebook, Twitter, email, and I sent out this
sort of mass email to all the people that
I knew saying, "Look this is happening. It's
not being covered in the media. What can we
do about it?"
I had written a song and I said, "A song is
a great place to start," [chuckles] and two
days later I got a lot of emails from people
saying, "We wanna help support this." But
one of them was from Peter Gabriel, the people
who I, one of the artists that, who really
inspired me when I got out of college and
he said, "How can I help? I wanna do this."
So just from using social media, a digital
communication, Peter and I worked on this
song. This is a song called "Open Your Eyes"
and him coming on board doing this song with
me meant that now CNN did a whole program
on the floods in Pakistan, Al Jazeera did
a half an hour program on the floods in Pakistan,
Canadian television, BBC, and media channels
in South Asia.
So it's -- I think if you don't act, sometimes
if you feel overwhelmed that this is so large,
what can I do? But if you don't act, nothing
will take place. But if you take a step, it
starts a chain reaction.
SSGWI is pretty much right now it's a start
up, but we've experienced 20 years of chain
reactions. Massive sort of chain reactions
and you never know what's gonna happen, what
door will open up, who's gonna walk through.
This is "Open Your Eyes". Each single download
of this song from iTunes is – it's less
than a dollar -- will go to flood relief
in Pakistan.
[guitar and synthesizer music playing]
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
Ahh, ahh, ahh, ahh
[guitar and synthesizer playing]
[guitar playing]
>>Salman Ahmad and Peter Gabriel: [singing]
Open your eyes
Open your heart
[guitar and synthesizer playing]
[pause]
>>Salman Ahmad: Okay so --
so after 20 years of seeing how empowering
arts and culture is: music, poetry, films,
books, Samina and I -- we focused our attention
on using arts and culture to help communicate.
We live in a world today – 2011 - in which
by the end of this year, there'll be seven
billion people on the planet. And we are so
interconnected whether we wanna be or not.
So diseases like HIV and AIDS, global warming,
issues of global warming, terrorism, nuclear
proliferation, they don't know any borders.
And these are all gonna be poverty, poverty
alleviation, none of this knows any borders
and the way we're gonna be able to make the
world a better place in the 21st century is
if we communicate solutions.
And so SSGWI is very much about communication,
finding solutions and creating a space, a
happy space, where everybody's saying, "Um
pun panama" and clapping in time.
So it's only when we see with the heart, all
the masks fall down.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
Okay, so if there's any -- by the way I was
instructed to inform you by Samina that we
have about seven DVD's and I think about six
books to give away. So whoever asks the first
13 questions [laughs]
[laughter]
that's I know an unfair way of doing this,
but the book is available. It's on Simon Schuster
dot com as well as on Amazon and all the proceeds
from the DVD will go to SSGWI and flood relief.
[pause]
>>male #1: I'd love to hear, I don't know
if you're in for this more by Western musician
[unintelligible] but I'd love to hear like
what [unintelligible].
>Salman Ahmad: Sure, it's a great question.
You know since the age of 11, I was growing
up in America, went to junior high and high
school, I listened to everything from Zeppelin
to the Beatles to Santana and then progressively
jazz, blues, Muddy Waters, Howlin' Wolf, just
soaking it all up.
Now days I listen to Radiohead, Sigur Ros,
and I try to soak up as much as I possibly
can but not just from rock but from opera,
jazz. My Desi or my South Asian influences
are, one of them is like I told you the story
when I was six -- Qawwali, I connected with
it unconsciously at the age of six.
But then later on one of the greatest, perhaps
the most influential Sufi singer of the 20th
century was Ustad Nusrat Fateh Ali Khan.
And I had, I tell his story in the book of
how we connected and this was when I was right
out of college and to be, have him as a mentor
and see him. It was interesting -- this happens
a lot in South Asia that you look at western
music and you say, "Well, that's western pop
culture," and this is Desi music, but he was
-- Nusrat broke the mold of the traditional
Qawwali singer 'cause he collaborated with
Peter Gabriel. He collaborated with Eddie
Vedder of Pearl Jam; collaborated with Mike
-- one of the greatest albums really if you
get a chance to listen to is "Night Song"
with Michael Brook.
And I saw that people who listened to rock
music like, rock singers like Robert Plant
and even Jeff Buckley found Qawwali to have
the same intensity as the blues did. Which
I listen to it the same way, they have the
same emotional intensity. So my work, and
then obviously Bollywood, I listen to a lot
of old Bollywood music which is great.
[laughs]
[laughter]
If you can just allow for the guy running
around the trees and --
[laughter]
[laughs]
It's a circle. Yeah.
>>male #2: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Yeah, that's a great question
again. Because the cultural influences that
were available in Pakistan when I was like
a child, you had much more coming in from
the West.
It was, look my mother went to a school called
Home Economics. It was set up by the Ford
Foundation. So there were American teachers
teaching in Lahore, Karachi, Islamabad and
it was a much more outward looking culture;
but a very strong home grown culture as well.
But rock music and all that was available
when I was very young. I didn't know that
much at that time, but in the 80s there was
a military dictatorship and a military dictator
by the name of General Zia came and although
he was fighting the Soviets in Afghanistan
those 11 years of military dictatorship completely
took the cultural vision of that country into
another age.
I write about that in great length. It was
very isolated. There wasn't really a cultural
vision. I mean all the culture he thought
that was permissible was basically the holy
book, the Koran, and that's it.
And so Pakistan over the last 63, a little
over 63 years, has been a country where there's
been a tug-o-war happening between the forces
of I call progression and the forces of regression.
And that tug-o-war is happening as of now
as well.
[pause]
>>male #3: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Okay, so he wants to know
about the experience of performing in Kashmir.
Does everybody know the political back story
to Kashmir?
[pause]
It's this, a beautiful ethereal place in South
Asia where since partition of India into Pakistan
and India, there's always been sort of this
conflict.
And when we went for the first time -- our
bend toured India for the first time in '98
-- we got so many emails from Kashmir, from
Srinagar of teenagers wanting us to go and
perform there. And I asked the promoter, we
were doing a tour all across India, can we
go up and do a gig in Srinagar? So he looked
at me; he said, "Uh okay. Don't let your idealism
make you run off a cliff. It's never gonna
happen in this lifetime," he said. And this
is '98 when he said that. And I said, "You
know what? We'll see about that."
But it took 10 years. Ten years later we got
an opportunity from the South Asian Foundation,
again arts and culture based non-profit which
said, "Look we wanna start building bridges
and we think music is the best way to move
forward and especially the kind of music you
guys play. So will you come and perform?"
And I was a non-brainer. I said, "Yes."
But as soon as that got published in the news
in India and Pakistan, I started getting death
threats from militants. They said, "If you
land in Srinagar, you will be shot on sight."
So I kept that information from the rest of
the band. [laughs]
[laughter]
I said, "Yeah, look it's gonna be great. It's
May, it's gonna be beautiful. We're playing
at this place called the Dal Lake." Anybody
been to Srinagar out there?
So let me describe this place to you. It's
a beautiful lake surrounded by the Himalayan
Mountains where legend has it that Ravi Shankar
gave George Harrison his first sitar lesson.
[laughter]
And that's where our stage was gonna be.
So I said, "It's worth dying [laughs]
[laughter]
to do this gig." [laughs]
And we landed in Srinagar and we got off from
the airport to the hotel in four bullet proof
Jeeps. And they were driving at 100 miles
per hour and there was like this sort of the
whole city was under siege.
And what had happened was college students
who wanted to come were prevented from coming
by this barbed wire all around the place.
And until the day of the show, we didn't know
if the show was gonna happen. But an amazing
thing happened and I tell this, this is the
last chapter of my book also.
Teenagers just decided they're gonna jump
over barbed wire. They're gonna get to this
place no matter what, and brave the bullets,
and there was obviously a lot of military
security presence as well. Literally guns
and roses because there are so many diverse
flowers there but so many guns.
Yet when the music started, it seemed like
that the sun came out. Everybody was singing,
dancing, and it, I don't wanna sort of exaggerate
what arts and culture can do. For those two
hours, a door opened, a door of possibility
opened. And for me it crystallized again that
if we wanna start making this world better,
safer, we need to communicate with each other.
And it was probably the most important concert
of my life -- that one, yet.
[applause]
Thank you. Thank you.
>>female #1: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: [laughs]
>>male #4: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Okay.
[laughter]
Okay, so let me do this. How much time do
we have?
>>Chade-Meng Tan: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: So I'll finish with Sayoonee.
Okay.
>>male #5: I was wondering if you have any
thoughts on [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: So great question. Recently
last week on the 5th of Jan, Governor, my
namesake Salman Taseer was shot down, killed
by a person who disagreed with his views on
the blasphemy law in Pakistan.
The blasphemy law very quickly is a manmade
law created by the same military dictator,
General Zia, who in order to segregate other
sex, Muslim sex, decided that if anybody's
gonna insult Islam or the Prophet of Islam
that there's zero tolerance and there's a
death penalty.
And what happened recently was there's a woman
in Pakistan, Asia Bibi, who not that there's
any proof but the fact is somebody's accused
her of blaspheming, and so there's an automatic
death sentence.
And what this Governor was trying to do was
to question, to look at, start a debate on
the blasphemy law. And just because he wanted
to start a debate, this man came and shot
him 27 times.
So what I think, I think very clearly, and
again I'm not some -- I'm not a politician
and obviously I'm not a theologian, but I
feel that Islam, that's my faith tradition,
it provides great platform for debate; has
for the last 1400 years. In the last 1400
years, there's never been anybody put to death
for blasphemy against Islam or the Prophet.
So in 1400 years all faith culture which has
now 1.5 billion of faith -- a tradition which
is 1.5 billion followers, why is it that this
particular law which is a manmade law still
-- isn't there a better way to sort of get
positive discourse rather than putting people
to death?
>>male #6: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Yeah.
>>Salman Ahmad: Well you know Martin Luther
King said it well. He said, "It was the appalling
silence of the good people." It wasn't so
much of the bad people, the rank core of the
bad people, I'm paraphrasing, but the appalling
silence of the good people.
So I think the first step is to recognize
what you just said. That this is goes against
everything that human rights stands for, goes
with everything that Islam stands for.
There's a line in the Koran which says, "If
you take one life it's like killing the whole
of humanity." And 99 percent of the verses
in the Koran start with, "In the Name of God
the most compassionate, the most merciful."
So my way would be to have a culturally sensitive
dialog. Not people accusing, finger pointing,
but talking about areas where we agree and
disagree. There has to be a serious dialog
about this.
Right now in Pakistan the situation is, there's
a great political turmoil going on. And people
just like here, after the recent sad events
in Arizona, what started happening was this
sort of finger pointing going on.
And I thought that speech the other day that
President Obama made was a great speech where
he said, "We can disagree with each other's
ideas, but not question their love for our
country," or in Pakistan's case the people's
love for faith.
I think a lot more people, artists, religious
leaders, writers, politicians -- you need
a basically a critical mass of people coming
together and isolating that. This is actually
a very deep question.
>>male #6: I know.
>>Salman Ahmad: Yeah. Difficult.
>>male #7: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Could you speak a little bit
louder?
>>male #7: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: What have been my experience?
Well I've give you a very simple. My mother's
family comes from Patiala which is in India,
it's in sort of Eastern Punjab. And my father's
family comes from Lahore. And throughout my
whole life when I grew up in Lahore, Patiala
was a place that my grandparents told me about
'cause that's where they lived for 300 years.
And so they would tell me about the City of
Patiala and the music and the cricket and
the food and the jokes and the humor. And
so there was a picture in my mind as a child
of this place of fun.
So when I toured India, I got a chance, we
got a chance to play in Patiala. And I actually
was taken to the house where mother was born
in. And when I saw that house it, these are
visceral things; our connection to culture.
I couldn't just take a picture of it and go
back home. I needed to do something with it.
And so I wrote a song. Then I asked one of
India's great classical singers, Shubha Mudgal,
if she would sing on this song with me. And
so this song called "Ghoom Tana", not only
did we record this song, but we shot the entire
video in Patiala and in Lahore.
And the house, it's on YouTube, it's called
"Ghoom Tana". It's shot in my mother's home.
I mean well where my mother was born in, the
house that my mother was born in.
So the experience is that -- look -- when
we take a step towards another, they take
many more steps towards you. Yes, there are
bad people everywhere. There are people who
just have very fixed views, inflexible ideologies,
but why let them take center stage?
Right now what's happening is you have extremists
who have the loudest voices, who get covered
in the news the most. They're on the front
page everywhere screaming at each other, where
there's a huge silent majority which thinks
about these things in a very different way,
but they don't make themselves heard. And
so my experience is that this catalyzes that
communication.
[pause]
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>Salman Ahmad: So collaborations yes.
So aside from Peter Gabriel and Shubha Mudgal,
and I did a song with Melissa Etheridge as
well. She's written the intro to my book.
I mean I've collaborated with lots of very
well known and not so well known musicians.
And like I said musicians, there's three C's.
If you're -- when we sit together if you're
a musician, there're three C's that come.
One is communication, compassion. Out of that
communication and compassions comes creativity.
And the interesting thing about jamming is
that we don't really know where we're going.
[chuckles] It's not like here's a road map
and if you hit an A chord, I'll go there.
It's like what do you wanna say? And you say
something and then there's a response. And
then there's a counter response and out of
that comes music and a deep dialog. That's
what I've got from whoever I've collaborated
with.
[pause]
>>female #2: [unintelligible] How can we hold
the door open [unintelligible]?
>>Salman Ahmad: Okay, so great question. How
can we sustain the dialog, the sort of these
glimpses that you get at concerts and people
coming together?
I mean there's been great over the years,
like you look at Live Aid, look at Live Eight,
stuff that Bono and Bob Geldof has done.
Yet people think that just because artists
came together and did a show that that's enough.
And so you can move on. But that's just opening
the door. You see artists can only open the
door; people have to walk through those doors.
Now a lot of you here, I mean this is Google
Earth. [laughs] You have the velocity here,
the connectivity here, to amplify the voices
who wanna change the world for the better.
And that's what I'm talking about as a collective,
but also on an individual level you can do
a lot. We're, we don't need CNN, we don't
need the New York Times, or Al Jazeera or
whatever, we have our own networks. And we
need to use those networks wisely.
I mean you can connect with me on Twitter,
I'm Sufi Sal, S-u-f-I S-a-l and look I'm here
to be educated. If there's some ideas of how
we can amplify the voices of unity we're there.
And I have a lot of music friends all around
the world who are just a touch of a button
away.
[pause]
>>male #7: [unintelligible]
>>Salman Ahmad: Last question. You got one?
[laughs]
[laughter]
Ahhh. We have very few ladies asking questions.
So --
Yeah, you had your hand up.
>>female #2: [unintelligible]
[laughter]
>>Salman Ahmad: [chuckles]
>>Salman Ahmad: So when I played at the Nobel
Peace Prize ceremony I go to my mother, "You
know we played at the Nobel Peace Prize ceremony."
She said, "Beta, son, when are you gonna become
a doctor?"
[laughter]
[applause]
Thank you so much. Thank you. [laughs]
>>Samina: Yeah, hello to everybody. I would
like to thank Meng for inviting us here. It
was such a pleasure to meet you in New York
at the U.N. TED and thank you to Zeeya as
well and Nabil who drove us here. It's always
a team effort. We're so delighted to be here.
Thank you so much. And Google is so dear to
us. We have attended two zeitgeist conferences
as well where Salman has performed.
This particular trip is special. We have a
concert on Sunday at the Spangenberg Theatre
in Palo Alto. And it's called a Unity Jam.
So one of the things that SSGWI does is also
to collaborate between Jewish, Christian,
and Hindu artists and we do this activity
once a year. It's usually on Martin Luther
King Day, so if anybody is interested in seeing
a klezmer musician or like a klezmer artist
group called Common Chords perform with Junoon,
please come at seven p.m. in Palo Alto Spangenberg
Theatre. It's called Unity Jam. We would love
to see you there.
And on another note, do go on SSGWI dot o-r-g
and check out if you have an interest in helping
out in our projects. We do interfaith work
using art and culture, but we also work in
health and education.
I just came back from Pakistan on the 6th
of January and I'm working on two projects
there. One is the Women's Wellness Initiative
which is teaching the Pakistani woman how
she can take care of herself, mind, body,
spirit.
Because that particular woman that I'm talking
about does not have access to health like
all of us do. She is illiterate, she doesn't
have access to a good hospital and doctors,
so the concept is to do workshops for this
woman and to empower her so that she can raise
a happy, healthy family where the children
are not going out to join the Taliban's. And
she has confidence as a woman, has high self
esteem, and teaches tolerance to her community
thereby becoming a community leader.
So it's a wonderful program. I really feel
preventative medicine is the future of Pakistan,
and of all the other underdeveloped countries
who don't have access to health care. So support
us on that.
And the other project that we're doing is
called Build a Village. We've already identified
a village in Sin, in Nata. I visited those
people, they are 20 families; they've lost
their homes; they've got nowhere to go. And
this project is all about building a holistic
village for them which will not only provide
shelter, but will also make education, health
accessible to them.
So really, once again, Meng thank you for
giving us an opportunity to talk about our
work. And thank you for coming here. Thanks
a lot.
[applause]
[pause]
>>Salman Ahmad: So we were talking about arts
and culture. The first time I saw Samina,
I was 17 years old and she was singing a song
and that song connected me. So it works. [laughs]
[laughter]
Okay, so Sayoonee. Sayoonee, the word means
soul mate. And this is a song which really
opened up my eyes to India from a cultural
standpoint because we were touring the country
and wherever we just sang this song, it seemed
like you made more and more friends. So it's
an easy job.
So if you come to the show day after tomorrow,
we'll do this with the whole band, but right
now I'll play you a little part of this.
[playing guitar]
[audience clapping in time to music]
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
Sayoonee, Sayoonee
Chen ik pal Nahin
Aur koi hal Nahin
Sayonee, Sayoonee
[guitar]
Kon morae muhar
Koi Sanval nahin
Ohh
Chen ik pal Nahin
Aur koi hal Nahin
Sing with me.
Sayoonee, Sayoonee
Your turn.
>>audience singing:
Sayoonee, Sayoonee
>>Salman Ahmad: [singing]
Sayoonee
[applause]
[playing guitar]
Thank you.
[applause]